one of the challenges with escaping
plants there was a fun paper when my
colleagues wrote that suggested that
super Earth planets may be inescapable
if you're a civilization that were born
on a super Earth the surface gravity is
so high that the chemical potential
energy of hydrogen or methane whatever
fuel you're using simply is at odds with
the with the gravity of the planet
itself and so you would uh you know our
current Rockets I'm not sure with a
fraction but maybe like 90 of the rocket
is fuel or something by mass these
things would have to be
um like the size of the the Giza
Pyramids of fuel with just a tiny tip on
the top in order just to escape their
Pantry atmosphere and so it has been
argued that if you live on a super Earth
you may be you may be forced to live
there forever there may be no Escape
unless you invent a space elevator or
something but then how do you even build
the infrastructure and space to to do
something like that in the absence of a
successful rocket program
um and so the more and more we we look
at our Earth and think about the sorts
of problems we're facing
the more you see things about the Earth
which make it ideally suited in so many
regards it's almost spooky right that we
not only live on a planet which has the
right conditions for life for
intelligent life a sustained fossil fuel
industry just happens to be in the
ground we have plenty of fossil fuels to
get our Industrial Revolution going
um but also the chemical energy
contained within those fossil fuels and
hydrogen and other fuels is sufficient
that we have the ability to escape our
planetary atmosphere and planetary
gravity to have a space program and we
also happen to have a Celestial body
which is just within reach the moon
which doesn't also necessarily have to
be true were the moon not there what
effect would that have had on our
aspirations of a space program in the
1960s would there have ever been a space
race to Mars or to Venus it's a much
harder certainly for a human program
that seems almost impossible with 1960s
technology to imagine ever come to
fruition it's almost as if somebody
constructed a set of uh challenging
obstacles before us challenging problems
to solve they're challenging but they're
doable and there's a sequence of them
gravity is very difficult to overcome
but we have given the size of Earth it's
not so bad that we could still actually
construct propulsional systems that can
escape it yeah and the same with climate
change perhaps I mean climate change is
the next major problem facing That
civilization but we know it is
technically surmountable yeah you know
it's it's a it's it's it does seem
sometimes like there has been a series
of challenges laid out to progress us
towards a mature civilization that can
one day perhaps expand to the Stars I'm
a little more concerned about nuclear
weapons uh Ai and uh natural or
artificial pandemics but yes I mean
plenty plenty of plenty of fun
Milestones that we need to cross and we
can argue about the severity of each one
but there is no doubt that we live in a
world that has serious challenges is
that are pushing our intellects now will
to the limit of
whether we're really ready to progress
to the next stage of our development